bonjour Marc fenou bonjour vous êtes
donc ministre de l'Agriculture de la
souveraineté alimentaire mais aussi
vice-président du MoDem le président de
votre parti François Bayrou a exprimé
des réserves sur le projet de loi de
réforme des retraites un texte a-t-il
qui mérite d'être amélioré ce que vous
partagez son avis alors il a pas
d'exprimer des réserves il a dit comme
son que c'est important pour un
responsable public que il y avait des
choses intéressantes qui étaient posées
en termes de pénibilité d'équilibre des
comptes
des retraites et puis de de
progressivité de la réforme et quand
même temps le débat pouvait permettre
d'améliorer le texte on peut pas être à
la fois responsable public pour ce qui
me concerne ancien parlementaire et
ancien ministre des Relations avec le
Parlement et pas pensé que le débat
parlementaire peut être utile pour faire
en sorte en sorte d'améliorer ce régime
de retraite et donc il me semble que
quels sont les pistes d'amélioration
vous voyez oh il y a sans doute et ça a
été ouvert d'ailleurs par la première
ministre des travaux à faire sur affiner
les le registre de la pénibilité
regardez comment se met en oeuvre la
progressivité clarifier un certain
nombre de points je pense que le débat
parlementaire il sert parfois à
améliorer les éléments de texte et
parfois aussi à éclairer les débats et à
faire en sorte que que les Français
puissent voir ce qu'on essaye de faire
au travers de cette réforme de retraite
font si je voulais résumer les choses
c'est assurer le système par répartition
et donc son équilibre
et deuxièmement mettre plus de justice
la question c'est ce que le système sera
plus juste après qu'aujourd'hui et à mon
sens il est plus juste après
qu'aujourd'hui c'est aussi comme ça
qu'il faut regarder ce système François
Hollande qui était interrogé il y a
quelques jours disait qu'il n'y a certes
jamais de bons moments pour lancer une
réforme des retraites mais qu'il y en a
de mauvais et que là précisément s'en
est un mauvais un mauvais moment après
deux ans et demi de crise sanitaire avec
les fortes tensions sur des prix de
l'énergie avec l'inflation qui pénalise
des ménages est-ce qu'il n'est pas en
effet un peu déraisonnable de se lancer
dans dans cette réforme qui rappelons-le
est très majoritairement rejeté par les
Français et puis aussi par l'ensemble
des syndicats de salariés parlons le
dire ainsi alors il y a l'habiliter des
mots du président Hollande mais la
vérité si jamais de bons moments c'est
qu'il y a toujours un bon moment et que
c'est à force d'avoir dit qu'il y a
jamais de bon moment qu'on n'a jamais
fait ses réformes qui sont des réformes
pourtant nécessaires
pour autant je comprends tout à fait que
certains puissent avoir des craintes que
dans le moment où les moments difficiles
que peuvent traverser les Français que
nous avons traversé avec eux d'ailleurs
puisse y avoir des inquiétudes mais on
le fait aussi parce que si on ne s'y
prend pas suffisamment tôt
le rattrapage qu'on aurait à produire
dans six mois un an ou deux ans ou 3 ans
ce serait beaucoup plus fort et donc il
me semble que c'est un élément de
responsabilité c'est pas forcément une
réforme évidemment qui est populaire
d'ailleurs je ne connais pas de réforme
des retraites qui puisse être populaire
simplement je pense que c'est une
question de responsabilité c'est ça
qu'on essaie de porter devant les
Français une question de responsabilité
et d'équilibre de ce système parce que
moi ma préoccupation c'est que le
système soit équilibré parce que s'il
n'était pas équilibré je sais qu'il
serait les plus défavorisés c'est les
plus fragiles d'entre nous ceux qui ont
eu plus de carrière hachée donc c'est ça
qui est à l'oeuvre qu'il faut qu'on
essaie de développer dans les semaines
qui viennent dans le débat qui va
s'ouvrir il y a eu une réforme des
retraites populaires c'était celle de
François Mitterrand la retraite à 60 ans
sur laquelle est revenue d'une certaine
façon se sont remis assez rapidement les
socialistes
et donc on peut être populaire
provisoirement et après on devient
populaire dans la durée je pense que la
crédibilité de la parole publique c'est
pas de chercher la popularité immédiate
c'est chercher l'intérêt et on essaie de
travailler à l'intérêt du pays c'est ce
qu'on essaie de développer au travers de
cette réforme le patron des centres
Leclerc est en colère incroyable dit-il
sur Twitter des députés seraient
désormais favorables à la hausse des
prix de députés veulent faire en sorte
que les multinationales puissent
répercuter sans négociation leur hausse
sur les consommateurs ça provoquera
utile de nouvelles augmentations de 10 à
30%, il s'agit donc de la loi égalim qui
régit les rapports entre les
fournisseurs et les distributeurs Michel
d'or Leclerc a-t-il raison non d'abord
il dit écrit pas la réalité des choses
c'est pas du tout ce qui a marqué dans
le texte donc je parle d'un amendement
du député l'article 3 de ce texte on
peut rentrer un tout petit peu dans le
détail mais qui vise à essayer de
rééquilibrer les rapports de force entre
la grande distribution je rappelle il y
a 4 centrales en France
il y A 380 000 agriculteurs vous voyez
que le rapport de force et pas de même
nature y compris dans les dans les
négociations et entreprises
agroalimentaires le texte initial tel
qu'il est en débat cet après-midi on a
commencé les débats hier soir il ne dit
pas du tout ça il dit simplement que
quand vous êtes à un contrat et que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord sur les tarifs il
faut que le fournisseur puisse se
délester de son contrat avec le
distributeur pour pas être obligé de
continuer à livrer au tarif qui nous
conviennent pas c'est ça me paraît une
forme de liberté du commerce qui est
excellente qui est excellente et qui est
de bonne facture deuxième élément on
peut pas se paraît derrière les
questions en permanence d'inflation
comme le fait parfois monsieur Leclerc
pour essayer de défendre l'indéfendable
parce que des fois l'indéfendable c'est
quoi c'est finalement de ne jamais
rémunérer à la fin des agriculteurs et
ça n'est pas simplement l'intérêt des
agriculteurs cette affaire là c'est
l'intérêt évidemment des des industrie
agroalimentaire mais c'est aussi
l'intérêt des consommateurs parce que la
logique qui pousse toujours vers le prix
le plus bas c'est une logique mortifère
pour l'agriculture vous souvenez depuis
qu'on parle de cette de cet objectif de
mieux rémunérer les agriculteurs de
rééquilibrer ça a commencé à fonctionner
oui mais est-ce que la grande
distribution a joué le jeu
elle a été obligée de le faire et y
compris ceux qui étaient les plus
réticents parce que c'est reconnaissons
à Monsieur Leclerc une forme de
continuité dans l'action ce n'est pas le
cas toutes les anciennes grandes
distribution faut quand même distinguer
ça fait des années qu'il est sur une loi
de la jungle qui se passe d'ailleurs
dans les box de négociation
mais reconnaissons que l'année 2022 y
compris dans une logique était une
logique un peu déréglée par l'inflation
a montré que pour la première fois
depuis 10 ans nous avions inversé la
courbe qui était une courbe
déflationniste en disant pendant 10 ans
les prises agricoles d'une année sur
l'autre étaient prémunérées de façon
moins élevée d'une année sur l'autre
agriculteurs ça n'existe pas même en
inflation faible allez à 8 entre 1 et 2%
qu'on rémunère d'une année sur l'autre
moins que les agriculteurs et donc c'est
un élément important on est revenu on y
reviendra par peut-être pas peut-être
c'est un élément de souveraineté si vous
ne rémunirez pas vous agriculteurs et
votre industrie ou alimentaire elle
s'efface elle s'affaisse elle disparaît
et à la fin qu'est-ce qui se passera
pour les consommateurs c'est qu'on vivra
de la nourriture de produits qui sont
importés et vous savez vous souvenez
sans doute comme moi il y a quelques
années il y avait eu un bon slogan je
trouve que c'est nos emplettes sont nos
sont non seulement nos emplois et nous
emplettes sont aussi les éléments de la
souveraineté du paix d'un pays comme le
nôtre et donc c'est une question de
responsabilité il y a quelques jours
lors de vos vœux au monde agricoles
puisque je le rappelle vous êtes
ministre aussi de la souveraineté
alimentaire et vous avez dit que l'un
des éléments l'un des piliers de cette
loi intellectuaire c'est le revenu des
agriculteurs or en la matière il y a
encore du chemin à faire il y a encore
du chemin à faire je le répète la loi
egalim 2 qui est à l'oeuvre actuellement
la loi dont on parle c'est une un
ajustement sur pour éviter les pénalités
de justice les appuis de position
dominante de la grande distribution sur
un certain nombre de sujets notamment
les centrales d'achat
et d'autres ajustements oui il y a pas
de il y a pas de souveraineté possible
s'il n'y a pas de rémunération parce que
si vous n'offrez pas des perspectives à
des jeunes ou des moins jeunes qui
s'installent de rémunération évidemment
il s'installeront pas dans le métier
est-ce qu'il y aura une loi égalim 3 non
alors je sais pas ce casque là on est
surtout des ajustements des gamines 2 il
y a une deux c'est il y a 14 mois donc
il faut quand même laisser vivre un peu
les lois ce que je méfie des lois qu'on
via des domaines dans lesquels les lois
s'ajoutent aux lois
reconnaissons que c'est un pas de temps
et je trouve que dans les débats
parlementaires je dis souvent trop de
loi tu la loi là on est sur des
ajustements et je trouve que c'est bien
et d'ailleurs la loi et gagne de le
produit d'une évaluation de la première
loi sur le Gallim et j'ai trouvé que ça
pour le coup le travail parlementaire
avait été fort utile vous serez à
Barcelone demain avec le président de la
République et 10 de vos collègues
ministres pour la signature d'un traité
d'amitié franco-espagnol ce traité
aura-t-il un volet agricole oui d'abord
parce qu'on a beaucoup de similarité
avec mon de problématique de sujet
devant nous avec et j'en parle souvent
avec mon collègue espagnol ou esplanas
et en particulier on aura des sujets sur
les questions de souveraineté
sur les questions d'accès aux
fertilisants parce que c'est un sujet
majeur pour nous et pour les pays qui
nous entourent et puis sur les sujets
d'eau parce que l'Espagne a beaucoup de
d'expérience dans ce domaine et
malheureusement ils sont victimes depuis
plus longtemps que nous des sujets
déréglement climatiques et on peut tirer
l'expérience notamment en termes de
réutilisation des eaux pour essayer
d'avoir un système vertueux pour
l'agroalimentaire ou pour l'agriculture
sur le bio le niveau d'exigence il y a
une harmonisation européenne alors le
cahier des charges et de même nature et
on a tous la volonté à la fois de
développer bio dans un cadre qui leur
permettent aussi trouver leur
rémunération on est dans une phase de
jeudi au passage on y travaille
d'ailleurs au ministère de difficulté
pour le bio puisque la rémunération
n'étant pas au rendez-vous évidemment il
y a un risque de compère des producteurs
bio merci Marc Fredo merci